[Music]
how's it going today we're on set with
kellian ride unfortunately Ryan is not
here Pennsylvania because we are making
something very very very very special
I'm cooking demo on how to make
margarita cupcake can you guys believe
it me demo
[Music]
they feel about juggling on the show and
they said they're into it so I need to
do a little practice just to make sure
tents like any event spice rack right
now
[Music]
we don't have a knife here but if you
see me able to do okay I'm going to show
you some things that I just learned okay
so you take a knife oh okay and then you
cut down the middle you get twenty too
much to it really allows to really juice
the heck out of your life I want to kill
exactly you can finish that yet this
Pacific Kelly and Ryan so excited also
we can actually I can go like share and
comment and make sure you guys leave
some amazing comments and say that you
think that my dessert deserves to win
the $10,000 for charity check it out but
now we're in the car I'm heading up to
have lunch with a Johnny Cupcakes
he is my absolute favorite and let's go
do that
[Music]
we just went through the ballot place
with a solidly ecologist we screamed I
wish you Sara go there and there may be
joining us very shortly she's right Sara
live trigger so she's like jerk or she
says no I don't think she's sensitive
she might be sensitive but I think she
can be tricked I carried around Adric
tricks with me all the time you guys
remember the one time did I add a
cockroach to my house and the ones that
I still have in my house that's your
fault cause like what instant so we're
having a nice little lunch here in the
park this is Madison Square Park neither
one of us will slip here you're visiting
beautiful Bosque oh this is Johnny
cupcake by the way you guys did it no
[Music]
I'm sure that's very very clean so what
are you tell the New York you know they
secret um I'm giving a talk well I give
talk yeah I just hand them away a little
trick if you like here we go I've got
some presents for you yeah we're gonna
have a nice and enjoying the park the
weather's great I just say Kelly and
Ryan unfortunately Ryan was not there
reigai dizzy man he's all the radio in
the world guys I don't know how he does
everything like I can generally like
wake up and shower and Ryan by that
point has already done a TV show you a
radio show no you knows the secret of
life I'm in Pharrell I should prob well
yeah you just can I show you a photo of
my pride and joy
is this a blonde moment or now you got
to show me a baby
ah I was expecting a baby and I got that
yeah I was like wait is it something I
should blog or is it like an interactive
wait there's something you should
probably get a new one woman got you Oh
magic for us
I'm are you really stoked on our new
friendship okay humming - 3 2 1
a ballot paper I see this little
container yep
in Japan nobody litters so they they'll
take their cigarettes and we'll put them
out in the pocket ashtrays that they
carry around so I'm going to put the
cigarette in here
belong to the little baby hand I don't
know Shawnee has inspired me so much
with my business I know everything about
this guy just took such a good story and
I do that his first business was being a
magician Turner that's what he's doing
so he's showing us how it's done my
first time on stage was actually doing a
magic show
know what I was little yes and let me
tell you how crappy that one
[Music]
there is boosting with another Greek
board on her back because she wants me
to boot with her you know what she's
good as well thank you yeah that's cool
Wow what am i doing this is dangerous I
see you in pieces doing this I'm like no
no that before those under your feet
look at how open this is it does not
open enough what do you like while I'm
driving me home let's go look at her go
Wow
I don't think she can stop she's like
graduate Chile for my track going
backward
[Music]
what you're doing that I just after this
come on no shut up boy okay
ah been there it was like writers mouth
and a horse to cope with one end don't
let me go
how's that oh great thank you God
anytime is the grant money yes papa
okay I'll join you that's amazing both
more fun the booth Detroit or the double
deck fight it is fun it's a super
unexpected I will say though we discuss
what happens I mean I just got on a bike
to the stranger and I was terrified
positive support so she was so scared to
be honest and then a stranger rolls up
on like a double-decker bike he stops
joke throught to get on this just
feeling like sure yes not he's like what
you actually not know how to ride a bike
I'm like I don't know so we're going to
apply that now weird to come see I
haven't a coffee for like 7 hours it's
really really killing my body I go more
than one hour
that actual
we'll go on chat hello that's fancy
screen so I get the cold brew or do I
get so Sarah's getting the bull drew
which means I'm going to take a sip of
hers she doesn't know it yet and I'm
going to get this week this is all going
to work out great I got to call drew
it's actually really good you can taste
this Sarah left and I forgot our coffee
and I'm so upset about it Oh
is the coffee but if you had it I'll be
really good but this is my first time
trying that serendipity it's very good a
job delicious if I ask you guys my
favorite color is or was or you know
I'll call a combination you guys know
it's camo and specifically purple camo
so yeah I'm a daily vlogger here in New
York City I own a holding company and a
skateboard company called fortune
skateboards and I was showing just
seeing some of the graphics in the first
one she caught her eye on was this
purple camel voice so I'm going to send
one eccentric - I can't wait guys I'm so
excited I'm freaking out you guys know
I'm not the best skateboarder but it is
something that I actually really do like
doing oh god okay yeah then I get made
fun of them to go to the skate park
because I'm like the old lady it has
like helmet and all the pads I gotta be
safe guys
safety first well if you one for the
wall and one for you to ride okay call
somebody thank you
well I'm exhausted today was a long day
but I had so much fun in New York I
really wanted to get some really cool
cinematic shots which is a really cool
b-roll and adds really cool music under
it but I ran out of time and I'm heading
back to LA very very shortly so I will
see you guys back there I had so much
fun hanging out with Kelly and all of
the rest of my friends this video it was
still great I'll see you guys later
and that's fine
[Music]